I actually have to take a little bit of
responsibility on Twitter recently I
don't know if these two things are
related however I pointed out on July
4th at 5:36 p.m. I pointed out that
Kanye West's new song that he came out
with has a lot to say about liberty and
that it shows a real sophisticated
understanding of Liberty more so than
many elected officials and not two
minutes later it's 538 so I guess
exactly two minutes later Kanye West
announced that he's running for
president did those two events have
anything to do with one another
I don't know but if I did have anything
to do with that I'm sorry or you're
welcome depending on your view of Kanye
West's running helping us to break down
the 2020 race not just Kanye but also
the president also Joe Biden hiding in a
basement we have the great Charlie Kirk
my friend Charlie founder of Turning
Point USA a national student movement
dedicated to identifying organizing and
empowering young people to promote the
principles of free markets and limited
government Charlie thank you for being
here it's great to be here Michael and I
think that's the ultimate cause in
effect who knows if Kanye is running
because it's you or for whatever reason
I can't tell if I want to take credit
yet because my first take on this is
that this is very funny and enjoyable
and I get a real kick out of Kanye and I
don't think it's gonna really hurt Trump
so for me I think this will make 2020
even crazier and even funnier to watch
some people though are nervous because
anything can happen in politics and
Charlie you have this unique position
which is you've been up close with
basically all of the characters involved
here Kanye the president and and
obviously so many other people in the
national political scene what's your
take on mr. Yeezy running for president
yeah I guess I'm one of the few people
that actually can say that hung out
extensively with Kanye West and the
president you're the one guy well I may
be can too so Indiana's are the only
people that can say that well look first
of all I'm a huge Kanye West fan I love
that conversion
Christianity and he's a creative okay we
have to understand that and for the four
people that try to analyze it just
through normal linear thinking they
haven't spent time with Kanye I actually
think this could be a very positive
thing for the president yeah I I think
of it and I asked myself what are the
two demographics that Joe Biden needs to
excite and it is black voters and
younger voters yeah and Kanye West if
you were to run and people say oh it's a
joke I say hold on dude we'd not learn
our lesson in 2015 like someone but a
celebrity status runs for president all
candidacies should be taken seriously
right and so I I think in some ways it
could actually be very positive because
the president in certain states can
definitely consolidate forty four forty
five percent of the vote and if Kanye
does Ron and he does file FEC paperwork
and he does get on the ballot and
understand there's a lot of barriers
there he could he could conceivably take
away a lot of the kind of younger voters
that might have been more likely to vote
for Joe Biden and some of the black
voters that might have been more likely
to turn out for Biden and so and in no
way do I think this is a bad thing for
president Trump and look the president
and Kanye are still friend and let's
just give Kayne credit I mean how many
times he wore that Magga hat around he
goes into the Oval Office III don't see
any of this as a negative towards the
president and again there's a very
interesting thing that's happening there
Michael where you have to ask yourself
the question what is a Biden tamps
reaction to this and I think in no way
is the Joe Biden for president campaign
thrilled that there's going to be a
different candidate entering the race
that might be exciting or getting
headlines outside of Trump because their
entire race they're trying to create is
a singular almost Parliament
parliamentary system referendum on the
president they want this to be like a
House of Commons vote of no-confidence
not a binary choice between Trump and
Biden and if there is a third candidate
it will no longer be a binary choice and
I think that Biden having no enthusiasm
no energy will not benefit from that in
the final point is you look at the
enthusiasm Donald Trump's enthusiasm is
almost double that of Joe Biden the
fight with the polling reflects and the
actual if the higher enthusiasm Canada
has the less likelihood of being
impacted by a third party entering you
saw this in 92 with Ross
w bush so I actually think this could be
very exciting and I'm open-minded to the
positive that's my take on it too I
don't think there are any Trump voters
who are gonna say well I was committed
to Trump I was very excited for Trump
but now that Kanye is in the race I got
a vote for Kanye I think so many of us
really like Kanye these days because
well anywhere the mag add that's great
too he is this kind of unique figure in
our popular culture in that he won't
stick to the script you know he says
what he thinks the conversion to
Christianity or the reversion was
terrific I know a lot of us really liked
that last album Jesus is king so we get
a real kick out of the guy but probably
those all of those people are more in
for Trump than they would be for Kanye
but it does remind me to in terms of the
voters who let's say they don't pay
attention to politics that much they're
not that interested this is why the
celebrities always come out and endorse
the Democrat as they want to convince
people who don't pay attention to the
news a lot that they've got a vote for
their candidate I think a lot of those
people you know the the ones who just
don't live their life by the updates
from Politico they could be attracted to
a Kanye West candidacy that is going to
hurt Joe Biden and and Joe Biden let's
not forget even fourth of July weekend
refused to leave the bunker he refused
to leave the basement
he pushed pushed that video in which he
basically excoriated America but that's
it I mean the guy can barely leave his
house and so when you've got two
candidates on the campaign trail one you
know both of whom are such huge
personalities Donald Trump and Kanye
West where does that leave iDEN well I
mean it doesn't put him in a good
position I mean look at once once things
start to normalized and I use that term
very carefully because who knows what
that even means anymore right and this
actually becomes some form of a
presidential race because you're
starting to see the market kick up today
which is a really good sign who's ready
to see people travel more and you know I
was stuck in traffic the other day for
the first time in like six months like
this is wonderful people are actually
driving again and they're getting
outside and so once once you start to
see America open up there's going to be
a demand of wait who's running for
president again and what does he have to
say all this then you're going to see a
five to ten point tightening of the race
both direction Biden's number will go
down and Trump's number will go up I
mean people think of Joe Biden from the
nineties where he's just this Daffy you
know lovable fake worker advocate from
Scranton Pennsylvania when in reality
you know he has very serious cognitive
decline and also once his true record
gets thrown out you make a very good
point Michael where the Democrats always
try to be the kind of sexy Hollywood
candidate yeah and if Kanye does enter
this race it disrupts that completely I
mean it almost it makes beyoncé and
jay-z's endorsement of Joe Biden look
kind of weird because they know Kanye
personally right and they've had their
spats and whatever but I again I I'm
actually I actually have gamed this out
to some extent where I see in no sense
if Kanye is a full-fledged political
operation whatever that looks like and
how entertaining that is in no way does
that hurt Donald Trump it just doesn't
in fact I think that it actually would
fasten Donald Trump's base even more it
would actually give Trump base even more
confidence and it has now that it can
win because if you look at Barack
Obama's political coalition that won a
no 8 in 2012 the last time the Democrats
won the White House he was the more
exciting imaginative candidate right ran
up against John McCain and Mitt Romney
for thoracic and Joe Biden's past the
victory is boosting turnout in those
communities that someone like a Kanye
would do really well and you saw how
Hillary Clinton failed tremendously from
that so I think that the celebrity
appeal is something that Democrats need
in order to get the victory I think
you're right and I agree I don't I don't
think it really hurts Trump so then my
question because you you have hung hung
out with Kanye a fair bit is it real
what's your read is this just a big
publicity stunt it's to promote a song
or something or is Kanye really gonna
try to get on the ballot or is he gonna
try to run a write-in campaign I mean
what are we really looking at here
beyond the tweet well we I don't know
I'd again I've spent good amount of time
with them and I have to say he's uh he's
a lot of fun he's very creative yeah he
thinks asymmetrically here's what I
here's here's my the best piece of
advice don't dismiss it at face value
yeah don't say oh there's no way he's
doing it and the more people who say
that the more likely
Kanye's probably going to do it kind of
knowing how we think psychologically
right more people that said you can't
wear the mag ahead and then he'd
basically like where the mega suit is
Trump in the Oval Office rested
yeah exactly this Iceland that was
before that was back when you can hug
people I miss those days but I'll tell
you it's I don't know but I can tell you
this that it's probably more real than
not see and that's that's probably the
the truth there and I look you have Elon
Musk contributing to it and the fact
that Elon endorsed him is pretty big
it's not that he endorsed Kanye that's
not the point the point is that Elon
didn't endorse Biden right that's a big
deal right
Elon supposed to sit down and obey right
like Elon gets government contracts Elon
benefits from tax credits in California
he's supposed to be a Biden guy and Elon
is looked up to very favorably amongst a
lot of teenagers and early 20-somethings
and so there is a there's a disruption
happening you don't see the the people
who are supposed to be consolidating
behind Joe Biden not happening as
flawlessly as the masters of chaos would
like it to be well the anyway the
architects of the Biden presidency right
I know I think that's totally true the
the enthusiasm just doesn't exist I mean
nobody is gung-ho to go out there in
canvas for Joe Biden who can't remember
his own name however there are these
troubling polls and I don't put a ton of
stock in the polls necessarily but the
movement since the coronavirus since the
lockdown you know 15 days to slow the
spread which was now I think a hundred
and eleven days ago in his ebbed the
economy has collapsed obviously because
we told people they couldn't work and
through 40 million out of work are you
worried about these polls I mean do you
think the Trump campaign is worried
about these polls and most importantly
of all do you think I should worry about
these polls well and look I've said this
publicly I don't think the recent
polling is trending in the correct
direction I do I take them at face value
no but even if I take them as half wrong
they're still not great right I mean the
question is they're wrong but how long
are they and so but again I attribute
this to a couple reasons to a couple
things number one this is not a
presidential campaign typically
and again it's really really interesting
because some of these networks by law
they have to cover the race equally and
that's a very interesting thing that has
I would love to see an independent
auditor go through and peer ABC's
coverage because just as a side note in
a presidential campaign like post July
4th they have to give equal time to both
candidates see it's by law if you're if
you're a network and the enforcement of
that is gonna be awfully interesting to
look into because I don't even know how
you cover bat bite you just have a
picture of his house here we are outside
of Biden camp he's still in his basement
he's in the anomaly today it's a
wonderful day in Delaware
you know 84 degrees and that's about it
I mean I'm half kidding of course but
you know once this is once Biden has to
get in front of human beings and not in
front of socially distant you know
coffee gathering where everyone's in you
know inside of their thirty foot circle
where they have his whatever that is
this is going to tighten dramatically
and I think the president if he strikes
the Tony did it Mount Rushmore where he
is the defender and the guardian of
decent America that's his message and he
gets America to think big and he has
very tangible specific specific aims of
how he's going to get America back to
greatness and real achievable results I
I think that it's going to be it's gonna
be perfectly perfectly I think it's
perfectly fair to say that in the fall
you're gonna see this race
tighten up into a bottleneck but then I
guess it's not a race that Biden won
this is my bhisma question I think your
analysis is spot-on but will we be able
to open up I mean Joe Biden basically
told us during that last bizarre press
gaggle though where he had his
hand-picked reporters he said I'm not
gonna campaign I'm not gonna have
rallies I'm gonna wear my mask all the
time he tried to blame it on the virus
and the doctors even though it was so
awkward he's saying we have to wear
masks but he wasn't wearing a mask he
said we can't go outside but he was
outside right he was at this press
briefing so it just seemed to be when it
was politically convenient for him to go
and show up he would do it but but it's
not politically convenient because he
has such obvious signs of decline so my
question is with the states locking down
again are we actually going to get a
presidential campaign are we gonna get
to that stage or is Biden gonna hide in
his basement all the way to the Oval
Office
well I'm glad you mentioned that we need
to open up and you know what really
positive lesson of the last week is how
you can pressure week Republicans into
doing the right thing I mean you saw
senator Mike Braun who came out and
supported the BLM Inc yep movement I
don't even I don't call it the phrase
because the phrase is offensively true
and it ridiculous something right yeah
you know exactly it's just so it was to
use that phrase million dollar yeah
exactly it's a multi 100 million dollar
you know money raising operations for
act blue you know he comes out and he
supports it and then Tucker Carlson and
myself and you and we come after Senator
Mike Braun yep incredibly aggressive and
he runs to the hills and pulls the bill
and says he doesn't mean it
well that's what we need to do to these
Republican governors that are shutting
down their state's again being about
what I've learned is how how 50 or 60
tweets from blue checks can make these
Republican governors very nervous we can
make these these Republican it's
incredible how much power we actually
have you know we convinced ourselves at
the ruling class on the Republicans I
don't ever listen to us it's just not
true yeah look if we make enough noise
even just one 2% of us you can change
their behavior so Florida Texas Arizona
I know these governors what the heck are
they doing the data does not support
relocking down your state's the quicker
America reopens the quicker we'll have
our economy back on the quicker we'll
have a presidential election post Labor
Day that's right we have a presidential
election in mid-september and we don't
have this vote-by-mail fraudulent scheme
that they're trying to implement yeah
that's a scenario where we can win if we
are not opened by September Biden it's a
higher likelihood of being president
than not this is it I think I think
you're so right on this I think at this
point in this second obviously
politicized lock down and at the very
least in this one
it's obviously not only a political
stunt it is the Biden campaign and and
the quicker we can reopen the better in
my view Charlie spot-on is always this
is why this way I always pay attention
to what you're saying charlie Kirk
founder of turning-point USA he's all
over the place Charlie my man thank you
very much
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoice a software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description